Hello. It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a bunch of different stories on that theme. And the best way to describe the theme of today's show is to kind of sidestep it for a minute and to begin with this story.
你好。这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，并为您带来一系列关于该主题的故事。描述今天节目主题的最佳方式，是先稍微绕开它，从这个故事开始。
One of our producers here at the radio show, Blue Chevigny, was living in New York a few years ago with a woman that describes as a kind of random roommate, an aspiring actress.
我们节目的制作人之一，布鲁·切维尼，几年前在纽约和一位她称之为“随机室友”的女性住在一起，那是一位怀揣演员梦的女性。
In the middle of the night one night, the phone rang. And it was some crank caller, stalker-y kind of person. He'd start saying these creepy things to her. And it wasn't just a crank call, because they knew her name.
一天半夜，电话响了。是一个恶作剧者，或者说是跟踪狂之类的人打来的。他开始对她说一些令人毛骨悚然的话。这不仅仅是一个恶作剧电话，因为对方知道她的名字。
Her roommate hangs up on him, and he calls back. And then she tells him off, then he calls back again. And then she stops picking up the phone. But it keeps ringing. And it's not exactly clear what to do. Middle of the night. So they call the police. Blue tells the rest of the story.
她的室友挂断了电话，对方又打了过来。她骂了对方一顿，对方又打过来。最后她不再接电话，但铃声一直响个不停。她们不知道该怎么办，当时正值半夜，于是她们报了警。布鲁讲了故事的后续。
So the police come. They come up to our apartment. We're on the sixth floor of a walk-up. They come up, huffing and puffing up the stairs. It's in the middle of the night. Our apartment's a mess. It's just strange having these strangers come into your house. It's just cinematic and disorienting. I mean, they're in their cop uniforms with these guns.
警察来了。他们来到我们的公寓。我们住在六楼，没有电梯，他们气喘吁吁地爬上来。当时是半夜，公寓里乱七八糟的。有陌生人进到家里感觉很奇怪。那种感觉就像电影里的场景，让人晕头转向。我的意思是，他们穿着警服，带着枪。
And one of them is this 40-something, heavy, balding, Italian-y looking, Sipowicz kind of guy. He looks like Detective Sipowicz from NYPD Blue, Pretty much exactly. And then the other guy is this younger, really good-looking black guy. And they both just looks like they're off a TV show about the cops.
其中一人看起来40多岁，身材魁梧，秃顶，长得一副意大利人模样，就像《纽约重案组》里的西波维兹警探。真的，简直一模一样。另一个人是个年轻、非常帅气的黑人。他们俩看起来都像是从警匪电视剧里走出来的一样。
They start asking us about what's happening. And we're explaining. And my roommate just goes into this whole-- launches into this whole thing about how she's an actress, and people are calling her, and people get her phone number off her headshot. It's got her picture and her name and her phone number all in one place. It's really scary.
他们开始询问发生了什么事。我们正在解释时，我的室友突然开始滔滔不绝——讲起她是一名演员，人们总是打给她，因为他们从她的个人资料照上获取了她的电话号码。照片上有她的头像、名字和电话，全都在一起。这真的很吓人。
And the young black cop says to her, "Oh, you know, I've had that experience, because I'm an actor, too." He says, "Oh, I don't do it much anymore, but, you know, I was really pretty serious about it before I became a cop."
那位年轻的黑人警察对她说：“哦，我也有过这种经历，因为我以前也是个演员。”他说：“哦，我现在不怎么演了，但在当警察之前，我真的很认真地对待演戏。”
They start talking about what it's like-- because they're both black, and young-- playing parts in plays and auditioning for things where there aren't that many parts that are interesting for black people. And it turns out that my roommate has played the part of Juliet in a production of Romeo and Juliet , in which she was the only black person in the play. And that he's played the part of Romeo in a production of Romeo and Juliet where he was the only black person in the play. So they have this in common. They're talking about playing Shakespeare. They're having this whole kind of very insider, actor-y conversation about this. Just out of nowhere. When really, looking at him, you would have just thought, cop.
他们开始聊起当演员是什么感觉——因为他们都是黑人，而且年轻——聊到在舞台剧中试镜，而适合黑人的角色却很少。结果发现，我的室友曾经在一部《罗密欧与朱丽叶》中饰演朱丽叶，她是剧中唯一的黑人。而那位警察也曾在一部《罗密欧与朱丽叶》中饰演罗密欧，同样是剧中唯一的黑人。所以他们有共同点。他们聊着表演莎士比亚的作品。他们正在进行一种非常内行、非常专业演员式的对话。简直是没来由的。当你看着他时，你真的只会想到他是个警察。
Meanwhile, the phone rings at some point in this conversation. And so they say, pick it up. And so my roommate picks up the phone and it's the same guy. And the cop that looks like Detective Sipowicz is gesturing for her to give him the phone. So she hands him the phone. And he gets on the phone and he says, "This is the NYPD. Don't call here anymore. If you keep calling here, we're going to trace the call and get you." He somehow indicates that they can catch him. And the guy hangs up the phone.
与此同时，在谈话过程中，电话响了。他们让她接听。室友接起电话，又是同一个人。那个长得像西波维兹警探的警察示意让她把电话给他。她递过电话，警察接过来对着电话说：“这是纽约警局。别再打过来了。如果你再打，我们会追踪电话并抓到你。”他以某种方式暗示他们有能力抓到对方。那个人挂断了电话。
And there's no more phone calls. The guy doesn't call again. Ever.
从此再也没有电话打进来。那个人再也没有打过，一次都没有。
After that, basically their job is done. But they still-- they're just kind of hanging around, talking for a few more minutes about this acting thing. And then the Sipowicz cop guy says to my roommate, he says, "If you're an actress, you should send your headshot to my sister, because she's a filmmaker. She's a small independent filmmaker." And we're like, "Oh, who is she? Who is she?" He's like, "Oh, well, I don't know if you would have heard of her. She just makes independent films." And we're like, "Well, we like independent films. Who is she?" And He says, "Nancy Savoca."
在那之后，基本上他们的任务完成了。但他们还是在那儿闲聊了几分钟关于表演的事。接着，那个像西波维兹的警察对我的室友说：“如果你是演员，你应该把你的照片寄给我妹妹，因为她是位电影制作人。她是位小型独立电影制作人。”我们问：“噢，她是谁？她是谁？”他说：“噢，我不知道你有没有听说过她。她只是拍些独立电影。”我们说：“嗯，我们喜欢独立电影。她是谁？”他说：“南希·萨沃卡。”
Who's this, you know, pretty famous little independent filmmaker lady. She made these movies that I had seen and that my roommate had seen-- this movie True Love that's great, and this movie Household Saints with Lili Taylor. And she's just a really cool woman filmmaker. And I look over at his badge and it says Detective Savoca on it. It was just bizarre. It was his sister was this indie scene woman. And he's Sipowicz, you know?
那就是那位非常有名的独立电影制作人女士。她拍的电影我看过，我室友也看过——那部很棒的电影《真爱》，还有莉莉·泰勒主演的《家庭圣人》。她是一位非常酷的女性电影制作人。我看向他的警徽，上面写着萨沃卡警探。这真是太离奇了。他的妹妹竟然是那个独立电影圈的人。而他却是“西波维兹”，你懂吗？
So it's just funny, and we're talking about that. And then the younger cop chimes in and says, "Well, your sister's not the only one who is creative in the family." And the Sipowicz guy gets all kind of sheepish and shy and is like, "Oh, no no no." And we're like, "What?" And the young cop says, "Well, you know, Detective Savoca over here-- Officer Savoca-- he just sent in his demo tape to Carole King." And we're like, "Carole King?" And I'm like as in, "I feel the earth move under my feet?" And he's like, "Yeah, yeah. Carole King." And we're all like, "What?"
这太有趣了，我们正聊着这个。这时年轻警察插话道：“其实，家里有创作才华的不止你妹妹一个。”那位西波维兹警察显得有点腼腆害羞，说：“噢，不，不，不。”我们问：“什么？”年轻警察说：“好吧，你们知道，这位萨沃卡警探——萨沃卡警官——他刚给卡罗尔·金寄去了他的小样带。”我们说：“卡罗尔·金？”我心想，是唱“我感觉大地在脚下震动”的那位吗？他说：“对，对。卡罗尔·金。”我们都惊呆了：“什么？”
And I was like, "Your demo tape? Demo of what?" And he's like, "Well, I'm a singer/songwriter." And I said, "And why did you send it to Carole King?" And he says, "Well, because I really like her songs and our styles are somewhat similar." And it was just one of those things where here you are, it's 1997. Somebody's style, anybody's style, is still like Carole King? Plus it's this guy-- the most Sipowicz-looking guy you ever saw in your life?
我说：“你的小样带？什么样的小样？”他说：“好吧，我是个唱作人。”我说：“你为什么要把它寄给卡罗尔·金？”他说：“嗯，因为我真的很喜欢她的歌，我们的风格有点像。”这就是那种情况，当时是1997年。还有人的风格——任何人的风格——竟然还是卡罗尔·金那种？而且这人还是你这辈子见过的最像西波维兹的人？
And it was just-- it was of those things, it was totally inspiring to me. Because it made me feel like just, as I suspected, as I hoped, it seemed that everybody was up to something extra on the side, had a secret talent or passion or interest, the secret thing that they love to do.
这对我来说真的很励志。因为它让我觉得，正如我所怀疑和希望的那样，每个人似乎都在做一些额外的事情，都有一个秘密的天赋、热情或兴趣，一个他们热爱做的秘密勾当。
One of the odd things about the founding of the United States of America is a phrase found in the Declaration of Independence, the phrase about life, liberty and pursuit of happiness. The pursuit of happiness. What exactly does it mean to grow up in a country where you have an inalienable right to pursue your own happiness? Did Thomas Jefferson and the other founding fathers really mean it's OK to fill our hours making demos, sending them out to Carole King?
关于美国建立最奇怪的事情之一是《独立宣言》中的一个短语，关于生命权、自由权和追求幸福的权利。追求幸福。生长在一个你有不可剥夺的追求自己幸福权利的国家，这究竟意味着什么？托马斯·杰斐逊和其他开国元勋们真的认为，把时间花在制作小样、寄给卡罗尔·金是可以的吗？
If you ask a historian who studies this sort of thing-- if you ask the historian who I asked, anyway-- it becomes clear very quickly that this is not their favorite question.
如果你问一位研究这类问题的历史学家——反正我问的那位历史学家——很快就会明白，这并不是他们最喜欢的问题。
That seems to be the big question. Everyone asks that. And there is no simple answer.
这似乎是个大问题。每个人都这么问。而且没有简单的答案。
Pauline Maier is an expert on the Declaration of Independence. She's written a book on the Declaration of Independence. And she says all anyone ever remembers or wants to talk to her about, when it comes to the Declaration of Independence, is this one phrase, the pursuit of happiness. As a people, we Americans tend to ignore everything else about this document. Instead--
宝琳·梅尔是《独立宣言》的专家。她写过一本关于《独立宣言》的书。她说，每当提到《独立宣言》，人们唯一记得或想跟她讨论的就是这一个短语：追求幸福。作为一个民族，我们美国人倾向于忽略这份文件中其他的一切。反而——
They puzzle over what does this right mean. If you have a right to trial by jury, that's pretty easy to define. But the pursuit of happiness seems somehow much more ambiguous. And I suppose it is. Because it is less concrete.
他们琢磨这个权利意味着什么。如果你有受陪审团审判的权利，那很容易定义。但追求幸福似乎在某种程度上模糊得多。我想确实如此。因为它没那么具体。
It contains a promise. And almost like the kind of promise that you'd hear contained in a rock and roll song. Here's one of the founding documents of the country, which includes the phrase--
它包含着一个承诺。就像你在摇滚歌曲中听到的那种承诺一样。这是国家奠基文件之一，其中包含了这个短语——
Which cares about how we feel about things in some way. The best scholarly comment on this that I've come across is by an intellectual historian named Ronald Hamowy who says, basically Jefferson left it to people to decide what gave them happiness.
它在某种程度上关心我们对事物的感受。我所见过的关于这一点最好的学术评论来自一位名叫罗纳德·哈莫威的知识史学家，他基本上说，杰斐逊把决定什么是幸福的任务留给了人们自己。
Happiness is, if you think about it, an extraordinarily private thing. What gives one person happiness is another person's discontent. Some people love to play golf. To me, it would be misery incarnate chasing a little white ball over all those green hills, under beating sun. You know, it's a very private-- it's extremely private. It's extremely personal. And there's a kind of an assurance that you can do what gives you the kind of contentment, that it was left to individuals to decide.
如果你仔细想想，幸福是一件极其私人的事情。带给一个人幸福的东西可能是另一个人的不满。有些人喜欢打高尔夫球。对我来说，在烈日下为了追逐一个小球在那些绿草地上奔跑简直是受罪。你知道，这非常私密，非常个人化。它有一种保障，即你可以做带给你那种满足感的事，这留给了个人去决定。
Still, we have a puritanical streak that is also part of our heritage. And for a lot of us, the notion that we're going to just pursue happiness-- it seems frivolous. It lacks dignity. It lacks moral seriousness.
尽管如此，我们确实有一种清教徒式的特质，这也是我们遗产的一部分。对我们许多人来说，我们要去追求幸福的概念——似乎有些轻浮。它缺乏尊严。它缺乏道德的严肃性。
Today on our radio program, a defense of the American notion that there is a decency to doing something just because it makes us happy. Our show, as always, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International. Today's program, The Pursuit of Happiness, in four acts. Act One, One Man's Treasure Is Another Man's Trash. David Rakoff heads out with 40 strangers in the middle of the night to tour the city in a completely pointless activity.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要为美国人的这种观念进行辩护：仅仅因为某件事让我们快乐就去做，这是合理的。我们的节目一如既往地来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台。今天的节目《追求幸福》分为四幕。第一幕，“甲之蜜糖，乙之砒霜”。大卫·拉科夫在半夜与40个陌生人一起出发，去进行一项毫无意义的城市游览活动。
Act Two, When Happiness Hurtles Downward Like Rain, in which we examine one small case in which the pursuit of happiness goes too far. Act Three, When Irish Eyes Are Smiling. We ask why one certain group of New Yorkers is far more beloved-- far happier, probably-- in Chicago than they ever are back home in New York. Act Four, How to Be Happy, One Man's Guide. Stay with us.
第二幕，“当幸福如雨般倾泻”，我们审视一个追求幸福走得太远的案例。第三幕，“当爱尔兰人的眼睛在微笑”。我们探讨为什么一群纽约人在芝加哥比在老家纽约更受欢迎——可能也更快乐。第四幕，“如何幸福，个人指南”。请继续收听。
Act One, One Man's Treasure is Another Man's Trash. We begin this show about the pursuit of happiness with a story about an actual pursuit-- a scavenger hunt, that takes hundreds of hours to create, done for the sheer pleasure of it.
第一幕，“甲之蜜糖，乙之砒霜”。我们以一个关于真正“追求”的故事开启这期关于追求幸福的节目——一场寻宝游戏，它花费了数百小时来策划，纯粹是为了享乐。
David Rakoff left the sober peace and relative quiet of his apartment this summer for a night out with over three dozen happiness-seeking strangers.
大卫·拉科夫今年夏天离开了公寓那宁静祥和的环境，与三十多名寻求快乐的陌生人共度了一个夜晚。
Jamie, captain of the white team, is reading the instructions to us, his five team members. Apparently, when we solve our first clue, we are to call into HQ, the nerve center, where, it seems, our progress will be plotted on a wall-sized map with push pins.
白队队长杰米正在向我们五名队员阅读说明。显然，当我们解开第一个线索时，需要打电话给总部——那个指挥中心，在那里，我们的进度似乎会被标在一张墙壁大小的地图上的图钉上。
This updates your location on the master map and starts a one-hour timer. One hour after this call, if you haven't found the next clue, you can call again for a hint. One hour? Oh my god. Half an hour after we give you the first hint you are entitled to a second hint. 15 minutes after that, if you still haven't found the next clue, we tell you where it is.
这会在主地图上更新你的位置并启动一个一小时的计时器。呼叫后一小时，如果你还没找到下一个线索，可以再次致电寻求提示。一小时？天哪。在我们给出第一个提示半小时后，你有权获得第二个提示。在此之后15分钟，如果你仍然没找到下一个线索，我们会告诉你它在哪里。
Although this scavenger hunt is called Midnight Madness, and is modeled after a 1980 movie by the same name-- a movie that Mat Laibowitz, the organizer of this event, has seen dozens, if not hundreds, of times-- it is happily only after 8:00 in the evening when all seven teams-- some 40 of us in all-- convene on the plaza in front of the World Trade Center. Believe me, it will be midnight soon enough.
虽然这场寻宝游戏被称为“午夜疯狂”，其原型是1980年同名电影——这场活动的组织者马特·莱博维茨看过这部电影几十甚至上百遍——但幸运的是，直到晚上8点过后，所有七支队伍——总共40人——才在世界贸易中心前的广场集合。相信我，午夜很快就会到来。
Our playing field for the evening is Manhattan, anywhere south of Houston and east of Broadway, an area which includes Wall Street, Chinatown, Little Italy and all of the Lower East Side. We will move from location to location, following a series of stealthily hidden clues. I joined Jamie's team because, like most people, I'd like to think of myself as being spontaneous, ready for anything, fun.
今晚我们的活动范围是曼哈顿，休斯顿街以南和百老汇以东的任何地方，这个区域包括华尔街、唐人街、小意大利和整个下东区。我们将从一个地点移动到另一个地点，寻找一系列隐秘的线索。我加入了杰米的队伍，因为像大多数人一样，我想让自己看起来很随性，随时准备迎接任何事情，乐在其中。
It will prove to be an evening of hard-won insights. The first is, I am lousy at puzzles, riddles, and games, with a negative capacity to solve clues.
这将证明是一个获得深刻见解的夜晚。首先，我不擅长解谜、猜谜和游戏，解线索的能力为负数。
The clue is "Three Eyebrows." You know, we're standing in  a bank lobby.
线索是“三道眉毛”。你知道，我们当时站在一家银行大厅里。
"Three Eyebrows" turns out to be an anagram for Bowery and Hester, not some downtown picture of Frida Kahlo, as I actually suggested.
“三道眉毛”原来是“鲍威利”（Bowery）和“赫斯特”（Hester）的字母变位词，而不是我建议的那种弗里达·卡罗的市中心画像。
It's a clue that says, "The shortest distance to this subway station is four from Union Square, five from Union Street, and five from Wall Street."
线索写着：“到这个地铁站的最短距离是从联合广场走四站，从联合街走五站，从华尔街走五站。”
This is actually the Delancey Street subway, not the Brooklyn Bridge stop as I posited, which is a good $6.00 cab ride out of the way.
这实际上是德兰西街地铁站，而不是我所认为的布鲁克林大桥站，那可是要多花6美元打车费的冤枉路。
Ah, there you go. There you go. Very clever. Very clever. It's a picture of the Artist Formerly Known as Prince. And [? the sighting is ?] Queen Elizabeth.
啊，找到了。找到了。非常聪明。非常聪明。这是一张曾经被称为王子的艺人的照片。而[？]是伊丽莎白女王。
This is a clue directing us to go to the corner of Prince and Elizabeth streets. Even I got that. I'm not a complete idiot.
这是一个指示我们要去王子街和伊丽莎白街路口的线索。连我都懂了。我不是个彻头彻尾的白痴。
All told, it will be an evening of over seven hours' duration before I finally give up. My team's peregrinations will take us, both in taxis and on foot, from the World Trade Center to Bowery and Bayard, to Bowery and Hester, to the McDonald's on Canal Street, to the Brooklyn Bridge, to the Delancey Street subway, to-- you get the picture.
总而言之，在最终放弃之前，这个夜晚持续了七个多小时。我们队伍的奔波，包括打车和步行，从世界贸易中心到鲍威利和拜亚德，到鲍威利和赫斯特，到坚尼街的麦当劳，到布鲁克林大桥，到德兰西街地铁站，到——你明白我的意思了。
There is anger. There is treachery. And there is a fair amount of boredom. Case in point, one particularly long stretch when all 40 of us stand around on the corner of Prince and Elizabeth for the better part of an hour, watching happy diners come and go from restaurants, gingerly nudging trash aside with our feet, unable to find the clues.
这里有愤怒。有背叛。还有相当多的无聊。举个例子，有一段特别长的时间，我们40个人都在王子街和伊丽莎白街的路口站了一个多小时，看着快乐的食客进进出出餐厅，用脚小心翼翼地踢开垃圾，却找不到线索。
I can just feel the puns raining from my body.
我能感觉到双关语从我身上如雨点般落下。
As abject as this extended loitering sounds, it's not. Some of the clues are downright beautiful. In the Delancey Street subway, the clue was a perfect mock-up of a Transit Authority notice taped to the white wall-- the font, the paper stock, right down to the two Ms for Midnight Madness, printed in that bold white uppercase letter in a black circle that indicates a subway line. Everything about it is such a flawless imitation that we walked by it three times before realizing.
虽然这种长时间的徘徊听起来很悲惨，但其实不然。有些线索非常精美。在德兰西街地铁站，线索是一张完美的交通管理局通知复印件，贴在白墙上——字体、纸张，甚至到午夜疯狂的两个M字母，用黑圈里的粗体白色大写字母印制，象征着地铁线。它的一切都模仿得天衣无缝，以至于我们路过它三次才意识到。
One year the game masters printed the clue in fake Chinese takeout menus and threw them around a building lobby. I asked Dan Michaelson, Mat's co-game master, about his favorite moment of the night.
有一年，游戏大师们把线索印在假的中餐外卖菜单上，并扔在楼房大厅里。我问马特的联合游戏大师丹·迈克尔森，他当晚最喜欢的时刻是什么。
There was a moment during the damage control when everybody was in Battery Park. So we got to see everyone at that time and walk around. That, to me, was a really nice moment.
在伤害控制期间，大家都在炮台公园，有一个时刻。所以我们当时见到了每个人并四处走动。对我来说，那是一个非常美好的时刻。
It's no great revelation that he and I might have different ideas of what constitutes a good time. People are rarely in sync. One person's gun safety lock is another person's abridgement of their most sacred right. One person's Barbra Streisand concert is another person's, well, Barbra Streisand concert.
他和我在什么构成了美好时光上可能有不同的想法，这并不稀奇。人们很少能保持同步。一个人的枪支安全锁可能是另一个人的基本权利遭到削减。一个人的芭芭拉·史翠珊演唱会可能是另一个人的，嗯，芭芭拉·史翠珊演唱会。
I know the moment Dan is talking about. It was when we were all at the War Memorial, a starkly beautiful plaza right by the water with about a dozen huge concrete slabs, 20 feet high by 18 feet wide, engraved with the names of the young men who gave their lives for their country. The players walk around shining their flashlights over the tablets, looking for the names of soldiers that correspond to the clue that has been dredged up from the depths of the Hudson River.
我知道丹说的那个时刻。那是我们都在战争纪念碑的时候，那是水边一个极其美丽的广场，有大约一打高20英尺、宽18英尺的巨大混凝土板，上面刻着为国捐躯的年轻人的名字。队员们四处走动，用手电筒照着碑文，寻找与从哈德逊河深处打捞出的线索相对应的士兵名字。
I might agree with Dan about how nice this moment was if it was during the day. But it is close to 4:00 in the morning. My brain has long since stopped functioning. My feet hurt. I am tired. And I am very, very cranky. Rats scurry through the bushes nearby. Mosquitoes buzz about our ears, their thoraxes no doubt full of West Nile virus.
如果是白天，我也许会同意丹的说法，那个时刻有多美好。但现在接近凌晨4点了。我的大脑早就停止运作了。脚很疼。我很累。而且我非常、非常暴躁。老鼠在附近的灌木丛中乱窜。蚊子在我们耳边嗡嗡作响，它们的胸腔里无疑装满了西尼罗河病毒。
Just then, Jamie runs into a friend of his. This friend is not part of our game.
就在这时，杰米遇到了他的一个朋友。这个朋友不是我们游戏的一部分。
I'll let you in on something. If you are a gay man walking through a dark New York City park at 3:30 in the morning, there is a reason for it. And that reason is not so you will run into someone you know. In fact, the last person you want to run into is someone you know. Actually, the second last person you want to run into is someone you know. The very last person you want to run into is someone you know accompanied by dozens of jolly amateur sleuths. With flashlights.
我告诉你一件事。如果你是一个男同性恋者，在凌晨3点半走过一个黑暗的纽约市公园，是有原因的。而那个原因不是为了让你碰到认识的人。事实上，你最不想碰到的人就是你认识的人。不，你倒数第二个不想碰到的人是你认识的人。你最最不想碰到的人，是一个带着几十个快乐的业余侦探的熟人。手里拿着手电筒。
Jamie's friend beats a hasty retreat. My co-Encyclopedia Browns go back to parsing the tombstones while I, in turn, come upon my second insight of the evening. I am no fun, no fun at all. Or perhaps I'm just a different kind of fun.
杰米的朋友匆忙撤退了。我的“百科全书布朗”队友们回到去解析墓碑，而我，则迎来了我今晚的第二个洞察。我一点也不有趣，完全不有趣。或者也许我只是另一种类型的有趣。
I decide to follow my own bliss-- the bliss of the quitter, the killjoy, the pill. Emerging from the park, I hail a cab. Hurtling through the deserted canyons of the Wall Street area, I settle back into the seat of the taxi. I'm on my way home to bed. And for almost the first time that evening, I feel happy.
我决定追随自己的极乐——那种放弃者、扫兴鬼、讨厌鬼的极乐。走出公园，我拦了一辆出租车。穿过华尔街地区荒凉的峡谷，我坐在出租车的后座上。我正回家的路上准备睡觉。这是我今晚几乎第一次感到快乐。
David Rakoff.
大卫·拉科夫。
[MUSIC - "EVERYBODY'S GONNA BE HAPPY" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - “每个人都会幸福” - 奇想乐队]
Act Two, When Happiness Hurtles Down Like Rain from Heaven. Back when Thomas Jefferson wrote the phrase "pursuit of happiness" into the Declaration of Independence, the phrase was kind of knocking around. People used it.
第二幕，“当幸福如雨般从天而降”。当托马斯·杰斐逊将“追求幸福”这个短语写进《独立宣言》时，这个短语当时正流行。人们都在用它。
And one of the ideas that it referred to was the notion that people would find happiness when they did things for the common good, teamed together for everybody's well being. A very democratic idea. In modern times we rarely hear the word used this way, the phrase used this way. If anything, when we talk about people pursuing happiness, they're pursuing their own happiness, sometimes at the expense of others.
它所指的一个理念是，当人们为公共利益做事、为了大家的福祉团结在一起时，他们会找到幸福。这是一个非常民主的理念。在现代，我们很少听到这个词以这种方式被使用。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是当我们谈论人们追求幸福时，他们追求的是自己的幸福，有时是以牺牲他人为代价。
We have this short story from Thomas Beller about one of the smallest possible examples of this more selfish kind of pursuit, of how we go from the innocently amusing of ourselves to less innocent activities.
我们有托马斯·贝勒带来的这个短篇故事，讲述了这种更自私追求中最小的例子之一，讲述了我们如何从无辜地取悦自己转向不那么无辜的行为。
Alex Fader grew up in an apartment on the 14th floor of a large, prewar building that took up an entire block of Riverside Drive. From his bedroom window, which looked north, he could see a broad patch of sky, the tops of buildings, a multitude of wooden water towers. And off to the left, visible only if he pressed his cheek to the window pane, the Hudson River.
亚历克斯·法德在河滨大道整整一个街区的一栋大型战前建筑的14楼长大。从他卧室向北看的窗户，他可以看到大片的天空、建筑物的顶部、众多的木制水塔。向左看，只有当他把脸贴在窗玻璃上时，才能看到哈德逊河。
The view that most fascinated him, however, was the one to be had by looking directly down.
然而，最让他着迷的景色是直视下方看到的。
Once when he was six, he suddenly rose from his bath, opened the narrow bathroom window above it, and leaned out. He balanced on his wet stomach, arms and legs outstretched like Superman, contemplating what it would be like to take the plunge, and if his life so far had contained enough satisfaction so that it could now reasonably come to a close. He stayed teetering on the window sill, looking at the distant pavement below, trying to imagine what it would feel like to land there and what he would be thinking during those thrilling seconds of flight.
有一次他六岁时，突然从浴缸里站起来，打开上面狭窄的浴室窗户，探出身子。他湿漉漉的肚子撑在窗台上，胳膊和腿像超人一样伸展着，思考着如果一跃而下会是什么感觉，以及到目前为止，他的人生是否已经足够满足，可以合理地划上句号。他一直摇摇晃晃地站在窗台上，看着远处的人行道，试图想象降落在那里的感觉，以及在那激动人心的坠落过程中他会想些什么。
Half his body felt the moist familiarity of the bathroom. And the other half, wet and gleaming like a dolphin, hung in the cold air of the unknown.
身体的一半感受着浴室潮湿的熟悉感。另一半，像海豚一样湿漉漉、闪闪发光，悬在未知的寒冷空气中。
Then a faint curiosity as to what would happen after his fall-- the ensuing hours and days, the circuit itself. He pictured himself in a steaming heap on the concrete below, and a few minutes later, his parents would be staring confusedly at the bathtub, full of murky water but empty of him.
然后，一种淡淡的好奇心油然而生：坠落之后会发生什么——随后的几个小时和几天，整个过程。他想象自己变成一堆冒着热气的尸体躺在下面的水泥地上，几分钟后，他的父母会困惑地盯着装满浑水却空无一人的浴缸。
The image of his parents trying to make sense of the empty bath was amusing at first but then became unpleasant. With the same entranced conviction with which he had got up on the ledge, he got down, closed the window, and resumed his bath.
想象父母试图弄明白空浴缸的样子起初很有趣，但随即变得令人不快。带着他爬上窗台时同样出神的信念，他爬了下来，关上窗户，继续洗澡。
Having decided he would not throw his body out the window, he began throwing smaller, less valuable objects. First, a cracker. It went spinning out the window and out of sight and its absence seemed profound. Next were water balloons, whose wobbly downward trajectory he always monitored until they hit the ground, after which the small figure of the doorman would appear hustling out onto the wet pavement, looking up. Alex loved the sight of this tiny figure, so formidable in real life, appearing on the sidewalk. But in watching from above, he was usually spotted from below.
既然决定不把身体扔出窗外，他开始扔一些更小、价值更低的东西。首先是一块饼干。它旋转着飞出窗外，消失在视野中，那种空缺感显得意义深远。接下来是水气球，他总是监视着它们摇摇晃晃的下坠轨迹，直到它们撞击地面，之后门卫小小的身影就会匆忙出现在潮湿的人行道上，抬头张望。亚历克斯喜欢看这个在现实生活中威风凛凛的小身影出现在人行道上。但在上面观看时，他通常会被下面的人发现。
Things were different at his friend Walker's apartment. Walker lived a few blocks south of Alex on Riverside Drive, also on the 14th floor. They were 10, and new best friends. And Walker was constantly surprising him with new and interesting ways to express malice. With regard to throwing things out the window, it was Walker who introduced the idea of a human target.
在他朋友沃克的公寓里情况就不同了。沃克住在亚历克斯以南几个街区的河滨大道，同样在14楼。他们当时10岁，是最好的新朋友。沃克总是用新的、有趣的方式表达恶意让他惊喜。关于从窗户扔东西，是沃克引入了“人类目标”的概念。
The windows of Walker's apartment all looked out over the Hudson River, and directly below was a broad, lonely patch of sidewalk onto which people arrived like actors walking onto a stage. They would stand perched at Walker's kitchen window, both holding onto a pot full of water balanced on the ledge, waiting for a suitable victim.
沃克公寓的所有窗户都俯瞰哈德逊河，正下方是一大片空旷、寂静的人行道，人们像登上舞台的演员一样出现在上面。他们会守在沃克的厨房窗户边，两人抱着一个装满水的罐子，平衡在窗台上，等待合适的受害者。
They once observed an attractive young woman walking briskly, with a bouquet of flowers in her hands, towards a man who was standing with several suitcases around him, as though waiting for a taxi, right beneath their window. He was a perfect victim. They were about to douse the man with water, but it looked like something incredibly romantic was about to occur, some long awaited reunion. And Alex and Walker instinctively held back and watched.
他们有一次观察到一个年轻漂亮的女子，手里拿着一束花，快步走向一个站在行李箱旁的人，就像在等出租车一样，就在他们窗下。他是一个完美的目标。他们正要用水泼他，但看起来好像即将发生某种极其浪漫的事情，某种期待已久的重逢。亚历克斯和沃克本能地忍住并观察着。
The woman had a strapless top on. And even from the distance of 14 floors, Alex could make out the subtle jump of her shoulder muscles and the tremulous softness of her breasts as they bounced up and down with each step. The flowers had delicate pink petals. The man with the suitcases stared at her as she approached with bold strides. His body was still and unmoving, his gaze fixed. He was oblivious to everything else in the world but her.
那个女人穿着无肩带上衣。即使从14楼的距离看，亚历克斯也能辨认出她肩部肌肉细微的跳动，以及胸部随着脚步起伏而产生的颤动。花儿有着娇嫩的粉色花瓣。那个带行李箱的男人注视着她大步走来。他的身体静止不动，目光锁定。除了她，他对外面的世界一无所知。
She walked right up to him and bashed him in the face with the bouquet, a violent forehand smash. The petals scattered like confetti. Then, without missing a beat, she turned on her heel and stomped back in the direction she had come, still clutching the considerably less flowery bouquet. The man just stood there.
她径直走到他面前，用花束狠狠地打在他的脸上，一次猛烈的正手击打。花瓣像五彩纸屑一样四散。然后，她没有停顿，转过身，跺着脚往回走，手里还紧紧抓着那束已经残缺不全的花。那人只是站在那里。
Alex and Walker were so transfixed by this scene they forgot to pour water on him.
亚历克斯和沃克被这一幕惊呆了，忘记了往他身上浇水。
Other people were less fortunate. Alex and Walker would stand guard at the kitchen window until someone appeared on Riverside Drive. There would be time to size up the target-- gait, posture, clothes. At a certain ideal moment, the water would fall forward from their pot in one solid translucent mass and then split in half, and then in half again, and again, so that what started as a single glob on the 14th floor ended as a thousand pellets of water on the ground. The pale pavement darkened, and the victim became completely still. This momentary freeze was, for some reason, the most delicious part.
其他人就没那么幸运了。亚历克斯和沃克会站在厨房窗户边守卫，直到有人出现在河滨大道上。他们有时间衡量目标——步态、姿势、穿着。在某个理想时刻，水会从他们的罐子里向前倾泻，形成一团固体半透明物质，然后一分为二，再一分为二，以此类推，以至于在14楼开始时的一大团水，最终变成了落在地上的上千滴水珠。苍白的人行道变暗，受害者变得完全静止。这种瞬间的冻结，出于某种原因，是最令人愉悦的部分。
There was one set of victims who stayed in Alex's mind for a long time afterwards. A little girl wearing a pink coat, white stockings, and shiny black shoes ambled down the sunny street a half step behind her mother. She looked as if she were on her way either to or from a party. She walked with unsteady steps and her mother walked beside her, looking down and talking, but also giving the girl her independence. They were two small objects alone on the sidewalk.
有一组受害者在亚历克斯脑海中停留了很久。一个穿着粉色外套、白色长筒袜、闪亮黑皮鞋的小女孩，在母亲身后半步摇摇晃晃地走在阳光灿烂的街上。她看起来好像是要去参加聚会或从聚会上回来。她走得步履不稳，母亲走在她身边，低头说着话，同时也给了女孩一定的独立性。她们是人行道上两个孤独的小身影。
The water hit the ground in a great hissing mass and they froze like everyone else. But in the several seconds between the pour and the splatter, as Alex watched the water fragment and descend, a tremendous pang of regret leapt up in his stomach instead of the more familiar thrill. As he watched the jerky, awkward expressiveness of the little girl walking beneath the water's widening net, he understood that there was a small corrupting moment about to take place. One kid introducing another to the random world of fate and bad luck.
水以巨大的嘶嘶声落到地上，她们像其他人一样僵住了。但在泼洒和溅落之间的几秒钟里，当亚历克斯看着水破碎下落时，胃里涌起了一阵强烈的悔意，而不是更熟悉的快感。当他看着小女孩在水那扩大的网下行走时那种笨拙、尴尬的表情，他明白了一个即将发生的小小的腐蚀时刻。一个孩子向另一个孩子介绍了命运和坏运气的随机世界。
[MUSIC - "RAINDROPS KEEP FALLING ON MY HEAD" BY BJ THOMAS]
[音乐 - “雨点不停地落在头上” - B.J. 托马斯]
Thomas Beller reading from his novel The Sleep-Over Artist . Coming up, a second story about New York cops, which'll show you another side of them that you have also never imagined. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
托马斯·贝勒朗读了他的小说《留宿艺术家》。接下来，第二个关于纽约警察的故事，这将向你展示他们你从未想象过的另一面。稍后回来，来自国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme. Today's program, The Pursuit of Happiness. Maybe it's just a coincidence, but in the years since Thomas Jefferson declared that it was our inalienable right to pursue happiness, we have pursued it about as aggressively as any group of people could. We invent pointless, time-wasting activities like no place else does-- the television industry, all manner of extreme sports, Nerf equipment. We are the world's biggest proponents of the idea of just hitting the road and starting a new life if the old one does not suit you. We perpetually create new ways to have fun.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题。今天的主题是“追求幸福”。也许这只是巧合，但在托马斯·杰斐逊宣布追求幸福是我们不可剥夺的权利以来的这些年里，我们追求它追求得比任何群体都要激进。我们发明了像别处一样毫无意义、浪费时间的活动——电视产业、各种极限运动、Nerf玩具。如果旧的生活不适合你，我们是这个世界上最提倡“走人并开启新生活”理念的拥护者。我们永无止境地创造着娱乐的新方式。
Which is sort of the subject of the next act of today's show. Act Three, When Irish Eyes are Smiling. Every year the Emerald Society, an association of Irish Chicago police officers, flies in policemen from New York City for Chicago's two big Saint Patrick's Day parades. Every year they are met by a group of South Side women. This American Life producer Julie Snyder tells the story.
这正是今天节目下一幕的主题。第三幕，“当爱尔兰人的眼睛在微笑”。每年，爱尔兰芝加哥警察协会——翡翠协会，都会从纽约市把警察飞到芝加哥，参加芝加哥的两场盛大的圣帕特里克节游行。每年，他们都会被一群南区的女性迎接。本节目制作人朱莉·斯奈德讲述了这个故事。
There are two main Irish cop bars in Chicago. One is called Dugan's in the not-so-Irish neighborhood of Greektown. The other is the not-so-Irish-named Ira's, located in Chicago's 12th police district. And normally these bars are pretty tame, filled mainly with men watching sports on the overhead TVs. But on the Saturday of Saint Patrick's Day weekend, everything changes.
芝加哥有两家主要的爱尔兰警察酒吧。一家叫“杜根”，位于不太爱尔兰的希腊城社区。另一家叫“艾拉”，名字一点也不爱尔兰，位于芝加哥第12警区。通常这些酒吧相当安静，主要挤满了看电视转播体育比赛的男人们。但在圣帕特里克节周末的周六，一切都变了。
The bars are filled with women, who are there for the New York City police officers, who are there for the women, who are there because they get to act in a way they never normally act.
酒吧里挤满了女性，她们是为了纽约警察局的警官而来，而警官们是为了她们而来，而她们聚在一起是因为她们可以表现出平时绝不会有的行为。
Normally, you wouldn't make out in a bar. Especially at our age, we're too old for that. But by 4:00, 5:00, 6:00 in the afternoon, sure. You can give somebody a big smooch at the bar. That's totally acceptable that weekend.
通常情况下，你不会在酒吧里亲热。尤其是到了我们这个年纪，我们太老了，做不出那种事。但到了下午4点、5点、6点，当然可以。你可以在酒吧里和某人热吻。那个周末这是完全可以接受的。
Kelly [? Farider ?] is a waitress at Dugan's, and she's the person who originally told me about the New York City cops coming to Chicago. But when I called her recently to find out more, she said she'd really have to take me to the source. So we got together one night in Tammy [? Tanzillo's ?] living room, surrounded by police paraphernalia-- policeman's hats, shirts, photographs.
凯莉是杜根的一名服务员，她最初告诉我关于纽约警察来芝加哥的事。但我最近给她打电话想了解更多时，她说她真的得带我去见识一下。于是我们有天晚上在塔米的客厅聚在一起，周围摆满了警察的物品——警察帽、衬衫、照片。
Tammy is 40-ish, completely beautiful, and is an attorney for the state of Illinois. She is also the original New York police groupie.
塔米40多岁，非常漂亮，是伊利诺伊州的一名律师。她也是纽约警察组的始祖级粉丝。
It all started about 13 or 14 years ago. At the time, Tammy knew a lot of Chicago cops because she trained supervisors in the police department. And one Friday night, like most Friday nights, she went to Dugan's after she got off work.
这一切始于大约13或14年前。当时，塔米认识很多芝加哥警察，因为她在警察局培训主管。就像大多数周五晚上一样，她下班后去了杜根。
And one of the cops that I knew was there, and he had a bunch of guys with him. No one was in uniform or anything. And he said, "I have a favor to ask you." And I said, "What?" I just got done with work, I had-- this was at least 12 years ago, I had on those big beetle glasses and a stupid plaid skirt. I looked more like a school teacher than anything else. Which isn't a bad thing but not in that circumstance. Anyway. So he said, "I need you to help me out." I said, "What do you need?" He said, "Well, I've got this group of 12 New York policemen here, that are here for the weekend for the parades, and I was hoping you could help me to entertain them." And I said, "Whoa. Hold on a minute here. What do you mean by entertain?"
我认识的一个警察也在那儿，他带着一帮人。没有人穿制服什么的。他说：“我有个忙想请你帮。”我说：“什么？”我刚下班，戴着那种大甲虫眼镜，穿着一条愚蠢的格子裙。比起其他任何事，我看起来更像个校老师。这没什么不好，但在那种情况下就不行了。总之，他说：“我需要你帮我个忙。”我说：“你需要什么？”他说：“好吧，我这儿有12个纽约警察，他们是为了游行来过周末的，我希望你能帮我招待他们。”我说：“哇，等一下。你说的招待是什么意思？”
And he said, "Seriously, you're a lot of fun to hang out with. Just have a few beers and keep them company and talk to them. I can't talk to them all myself." So I begrudgingly said yes.
他说：“说真的，你很好相处。只要喝几杯啤酒，陪伴他们，和他们聊聊。我自己应付不过来。”所以我勉强答应了。
Well, we had so much fun that from that day on, I was glued to them.
嗯，我们玩得太开心了，从那天起，我就离不开他们了。
The first year, there were 12 guys brought by the Emerald Society into Chicago. By this past year, it had grown to 160 men and women from the New York City police department to march in the Saint Patrick's Day parades. And it's no wonder they come. They're feted at the parades, at parties thrown in their honor, and at the local bars. They're kept on an itinerary that seems completely geared toward making the police officers feel like kings and queens.
第一年，翡翠协会带了12个人到芝加哥。到去年，已经增加到160名来自纽约市警察局的男女警官来参加圣帕特里克节游行。他们来这里也就不足为奇了。他们在游行中被奉为座上宾，在为他们举办的派对和当地酒吧里受到款待。他们的日程安排似乎完全是为了让这些警察感到自己是国王和女王。
They are ready to go from the minute that they are feted at Chicago. And that's why a little bit they are followed around. And there are young ladies that-- I think the word is on the street that they're coming to town.
他们从踏上芝加哥的那一刻起就准备好了。这就是为什么他们有点被追随的原因。有些年轻女士——我想街上都在传他们要来城里了。
I've gotten to be more of a mother figure to some of these guys. I mean, there's a drill. When I show up at the parade, I see them, and I say, make sure that you take your shields off. Make sure that you keep your uniform. Make sure that you stay with the group. Make sure that you don't give away your collar brass too early, because it's going to go up in stock as the weekend goes by.
我成了这些人中的“母亲”形象。我的意思是，有一套规矩。当我在游行中露面时，我会看到他们，我说，确保把徽章摘下来。确保保持制服整洁。确保和团队在一起。确保不要太早把衣领上的金属徽章送人，因为随着周末的推移，它会越来越值钱。
OK. A quick explanation. The officers have to take off their shields, or their badges, because the New York Police Department doesn't officially sanction their trip to Chicago. They have to watch their clothes-- their hats, their jackets, their shirts-- because as the drinking continues, and as the flirting continues, women are constantly taking their things and trying them on. One year, when the weekend was over, Tammy had to FedEx one of the $300 uniform jackets back to a New York precinct.
好的，简单解释一下。警官们必须摘下徽章，因为纽约警察局并不正式批准他们去芝加哥。他们得留意自己的衣服——帽子、夹克、衬衫——因为随着酒越喝越多，调情越来越多，女性总是会拿他们的东西去试穿。有一年，周末结束后，塔米不得不把一件300美元的制服夹克快递回纽约的一个分局。
And then there's the collar brass.
还有领口的金属徽章。
Everybody, all the women especially, are vying for the collar brass. And I'll show you what that is. Now I have a box about the size of a shoe box full of little numbers. And I couldn't find it, but I did find this little one. And this is what they are. As you can see, they're just about short of an inch high and, depending upon the letter, about an inch long. But that says two four, that'd be the two four. That'd be the 24th precinct in New York. I mean, it becomes a real clothes fest.
每个人，尤其是所有女性，都在争抢那些金属徽章。我可以给你看看那是什么。现在我有一个鞋盒大小的盒子，里面装满了小数字。我找不到那个盒子了，但我找到了这一个小小的。这些就是它们。如你所见，它们还不到一英寸高，根据字母不同，大约一英寸长。但这上面写着24，那是指24分局。纽约的24分局。我的意思是，这变成了一场真正的衣服盛宴。
Well, I'm showing you some of the pictures of what I look like by the end of the night. You know, I mean, that guy's getting a little frisky there. And there was one in here where I was looking really like I was having a good time for a long time. There we go.
好吧，我给你看一些照片，看看我晚上结束时是什么样子的。你知道，我的意思是，那个家伙在那儿有点轻浮了。这里有一张照片，我看起来确实玩得很开心。就在这里。
You're in a police officer's shirt and hat--
你穿着警察的衬衫和帽子——
That's just not a shirt, that would be a sergeant's shirt.
那不仅仅是一件衬衫，那是一件警佐的衬衫。
Sorry. The sergeant's shirt. Now are these all the pictures you have, or do you have more than this?
抱歉。那件警佐衬衫。现在这些是你所有的照片吗，还是你有更多？
Oh, no, I have tons and tons of pictures. In fact, they'll send pictures. This is a picture of Mike, who is the person that now is still coordinating the trip. And you can tell he's having a good time-- big smile on his face, cute young lady sitting on his lap. And Brian.
噢，不，我有成吨的照片。事实上，他们会寄照片过来。这是迈克的照片，他现在还在协调这次行程。你可以看出他玩得很开心——脸上挂着灿烂的笑容，有个可爱的年轻女士坐在他腿上。还有布莱恩。
Who's Brian?
布莱恩是谁？
Brian is the police officer that I met the first year that they had the group here, that I probably will always have a little bit of a crush on. But then there's Joey.
布莱恩是他们第一年把队伍带来这里时我遇到的那个警察，我可能永远都会对他有一点点迷恋。但还有乔伊。
This weekend, Saint Patrick's Day weekend, is not really Tammy's actual life. She's a grown up, an attorney who's now in a long-term relationship. But that's the beauty of it all with the New York cops, because none of it is real. Tammy says that all normal, real-life ways of dating don't apply that weekend.
这个周末，圣帕特里克节周末，并不是塔米的真实生活。她是个成年人，是一名律师，现在有一段长期的感情关系。但这正是所有这一切与纽约警察交往的美妙之处，因为这一切都不是真实的。塔米说，那种周末，所有正常、现实生活中的约会方式都不适用。
How many romances do you think that you've had through the Saint Patrick's Day weekends?
你觉得你经历过多少个圣帕特里克节周末的浪漫故事？
During this pause, I can't tell if Tammy's deciding whether to answer the question or counting.
在这停顿期间，我看不出塔米是在决定是否回答这个问题，还是在数数。
I think I have to protect the innocent here. I have taken a shine to a few gentlemen over the years, but always realizing that-- I've had a guy come back over the past couple of years that I've enjoyed some time with. But I'm seeing someone now, so-- you know, your life doesn't stop.
我想我得保护无辜者。这些年来我对几位绅士产生过好感，但总是意识到——过去几年有个男人回来过，我跟他共度了一段美好时光。但我现在有在交往的人了，所以——你知道，你的生活不会停止。
Once, when Tammy was dating someone and Saint Patrick's Day was coming up, she told her boyfriend that he may not be seeing much of her that weekend, that maybe it was a good time for him to go on a short, three-day vacation to Wisconsin. She says the following year she didn't even have to ask him to leave. He just knew.
有一次，当塔米在和一个男人交往，而圣帕特里克节快到了，她告诉男朋友那个周末他可能见不到她，或许那是他去威斯康星州短途度假三天的好时机。她说第二年她甚至不用开口让他离开。他自己就知道了。
All of this might come as a surprise to the citizens of New York City where, to put it mildly, these same New York cops don't get this kind of adulation. Like they say, nobody's a prophet in his own land. Even Tammy, who started a website called NYPD Love, can't explain what makes them seem so larger than life. Tammy comes from a whole Chicago law enforcement family. She says she loves Chicago cops, but the New York police feel different and special.
所有这一切可能会让纽约市民感到惊讶，在那里，客气点说，同样的这些纽约警察并没有得到这种推崇。就像他们说的，故乡出不了先知。即使是开了名为“NYPD之恋”网站的塔米，也无法解释是什么让他们看起来如此高大上。塔米来自芝加哥一个完整的执法家庭。她说她爱芝加哥警察，但纽约警察感觉不同，感觉很特别。
Maybe out here in the Second City, the NYPD gets respect because they seem like the real police, the police we see on TV, the police who just sound like police.
也许在这里，在这个“第二城市”，纽约警察受到尊重是因为他们看起来像是真正的警察，我们在电视上看到的警察，听起来就像警察的警察。
I think it's something about those accents.
我想这和那些口音有关。
Oh, their New York accents?
噢，他们的纽约口音？
Yeah. It's so real. It's so real. I mean, they sound so genuine. And most of them really are.
对。太真实了。太真实了。我的意思是，他们听起来很地道。而且他们大多数人确实很地道。
To put all this in context, this happens in the Irish part of Chicago's South Side, where lots of people have cops as family and friends. During a weekend when the whole neighborhood turns itself over to one big party, the main event is the South Side Saint Paddy's Parade on Sunday. The parade route on Western Avenue is lined with dingy little Irish bars, the sidewalks are clogged, backyard parties are thrown-- even some with those big white tents-- and you'll hear this song sung over and over and over.
为了把所有这些放在背景中，这一切发生在芝加哥南区的爱尔兰社区，那里很多人都有警察亲友。在一个整个社区都变成大派对的周末，主要的活动是周日的南区圣帕特里克节游行。西大道的游行路线上排满了破旧的小爱尔兰酒吧，人行道上挤满了人，后院举办着派对——甚至有些还搭起了那种白色大帐篷——你会听到这首歌一遍又一遍地唱着。
[SINGING] "Oh we're the South Side Irish like our fathers were before. We come from the Windy City and we're Irish to the core. From Bridgeport to Beverly, from Midway to South Shore, oh, we're the South Side Irish," and then it goes on and on and on.
[唱] “噢，我们是南区爱尔兰人，就像我们的先辈一样。我们来自风城，我们骨子里是爱尔兰人。从布里奇波特到贝弗利，从中途机场到南岸，噢，我们是南区爱尔兰人，”然后一直唱下去。
You know that song. I couldn't even have sung it. And I've heard that about 10,000 times. It's even on the jukebox, actually, in a lot of neighborhood pubs.
你知道那首歌。我甚至没法唱出来。我大概听过那个一万次了。其实在很多社区酒吧的自动点唱机里都有这首歌。
And most people, in fact, growing up on the South Side with everybody going to the parade, a lot of people know that they're not going to work Monday. They're not kidding themselves, so they take the day off. And growing up out there, it can sort of be a family event too. Because people's parents, they know you go to the parade, but they're going to have dinner waiting back at the house. So you come back, eat dinner. You go to so-and-so's aunt's.
而且大多数人，事实上，在南区长大，每个人都参加游行，很多人都知道周一他们不会去上班了。他们不自欺欺人，所以他们请了假。在那儿长大，这也可以算是一个家庭活动。因为人们的父母，他们知道你去参加游行，但他们会在家里准备好晚餐。所以你回来，吃晚饭。然后去某某人的阿姨家。
I mean, there's a lot of-- I guess it's kind of like Christmas without the presents, but then a lot more beer.
我的意思是，有很多——我想这有点像没有礼物的圣诞节，但啤酒多得多。
Or maybe like New Year's Eve, I suggest. Tammy and Kelly both say, no, it's way better. There's no pressure to look your best, or have the right date or do something significant to mark another year. The great thing about Saint Patrick's Day, they tell me, is that it's not really about anything. So you can make it into whatever you want.
或者也许像除夕夜，我建议道。塔米和凯莉都说，不，这好得多。没有那种要让自己看起来最美、要有合适的约会对象或做些有意义的事情来标记又一年的压力。关于圣帕特里克节，她们告诉我，最棒的一点是它其实没关任何事。所以你可以把它变成任何你想要的。
This American Life senior producer Julie Snyder.
《美国生活》资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德。
[MUSIC - "SOUTH SIDE IRISH" BY THE IRISH CHOIR]
[音乐 - “南区爱尔兰人” - 爱尔兰合唱团]
Act Four, How to be Happy, One Man's Guide.
第四幕，“如何幸福，个人指南”。
Finding happiness is serious business. Or it can be. I think for many of us, it requires an act of will. Nancy Updike tells this story of somebody who decided to turn something that made him unhappy into the opposite.
寻找幸福是一件严肃的事情。或者可以是。我想对我们许多人来说，这需要一种意志力。南希·厄普代克讲述了一个决定将让他不快乐的事情变成相反东西的人的故事。
Marcus Johnson runs a boxing gym on Santa Monica Boulevard in Los Angeles and he's a great teacher. To explain what makes him so good, let me ask you a question. Have you ever had a parent try to teach you a sport? Where they push you way too hard and you can see them getting more and more frustrated and disappointed. And on the inside you give up, but on the outside you keep going. And they keep going too. And both of you just end up miserable.
马库斯·约翰逊在洛杉矶圣莫尼卡大道经营一家拳击馆，他是一位伟大的老师。为了解释他为什么这么棒，让我问你一个问题。你有没有过父母试图教你运动？他们把你逼得太紧，你可以看到他们越来越沮丧和失望。而你在内心放弃了，但在外表上你还在坚持。他们也还在坚持。你们两个最终都痛苦不堪。
Marcus is the opposite of that. He's like a good date, where everything feels both easy and serious at the same time. He's always paying attention, always murmuring directions and encouragement.
马库斯正好相反。他就像一个好的约会对象，一切都感觉既轻松又严肃。他总是很专注，总是低声嘟囔着指令和鼓励。
Don't raise up, squat down. Step. Step. There you go. Step. There you go.
别抬起来，蹲下去。跨步。跨步。就这样。跨步。就这样。
All of Marcus's clients are adults, except this one, who's the son of a friend. Josh is 11 and this is his first lesson. Josh is, frankly, adorable. He has big brown eyes, dark curly hair, and dimples when he smiles. And he's making a very common beginner's mistake, which is starting his punches from way too far back, telegraphing his every move.
马库斯所有的客户都是成年人，除了这一个，是一个朋友的儿子。乔希11岁，这是他第一次上课。乔希坦白说，非常可爱。他有大大的棕色眼睛，深色卷发，笑起来有酒窝。他犯了一个初学者非常常见的错误，那就是出拳从太靠后的地方开始，提前暴露了他的每一个动作。
Marcus keeps telling Josh he has to be quicker and throw shorter punches. Finally Marcus just starts moving the pads away before Josh can hit them, to show him what can happen with too big a wind-up.
马库斯一直告诉乔希他必须更快，出拳要更短。最后马库斯只是在乔希击中前就把护靶移开，让他看看动作幅度太大可能发生的事。
It's not fair.
这不公平。
Come on, you keep putting your hands back, you're letting me know. You've got to be quick. From right there. Come on. That's how it's got to be.
来吧，你一直把手往后缩，你让我知道了。你必须快一点。从那儿开始。来吧。就得是那样。
This tastes like I just had a Fruit Roll-up.
这味道尝起来像我刚吃了果味卷。
Did you catch that? Josh made a face and said, "It tastes like I just had a Fruit Roll-up."
你听到了吗？乔希做了个鬼脸说：“味道尝起来像我刚吃了果味卷。”
What did that come from? A Fruit Roll-up?
那话从哪儿来的？果味卷？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Boxers are supposed to-- Boxers are not supposed to be--
拳击手应该——拳击手不应该是——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The two of them had a ball and Josh visibly improved over the course of just an hour. He relaxed, which is the hardest part of boxing. And then something really sad happened. After Josh was finished, his father walked over. He'd been on his cell phone in the back of the gym the whole time. And he started making Josh do these special tough-guy push-ups, something about keeping your butt in the air and only lowering your chest to the floor.
他们两个玩得很开心，乔希在仅仅一个小时内就有了明显的进步。他放松了下来，这是拳击中最难的部分。然后发生了一件真的很悲伤的事情。乔希结束后，他的父亲走了过来。他整个过程一直在拳馆后面用手机。他开始让乔希做这些特殊的强硬俯卧撑，关于保持屁股悬空，只让胸部降到地板。
And then push yourself up from there. One more time. One more time.
然后从那里把自己推起来。再来一次。再来一次。
He just went a whole hour, man, boxing.
他刚才已经整整打了一个小时拳了，伙计。
One more time. That's it. You see? Your butt hit the floor before your chest did. You done? Or you dead?
再来一次。就是这样。看到了吗？你的屁股比胸部先碰到地板。你做完了？还是你死定了？
You could just see Josh withdraw and get sullen over the course of these exercises. But then even after that-- and I swear I am not making this up-- Josh's father made him read a paragraph about responsibility from some pamphlet out loud, twice, because Josh stumbled the first time.
你可以看到乔希在这些练习过程中退缩并变得阴郁。但即使在这之后——我发誓我没有编造——乔希的父亲让他大声朗读小册子上一段关于责任的文字，读了两次，因为乔希第一次读得磕磕绊绊。
No stuttering. Come on.
别结巴。来吧。
I have to memorize this?
我要背诵这个？
You will. But right now you have to read it clearly. And loud.
你会的。但现在你要读清楚。大声点。
Um. "Responsibility. Responsibility starts with saying you were cause in the matter."
嗯。“责任。责任始于承认你是这件事情的原因。”
What makes Marcus such a good teacher is that he's not an over-eager parent. And maybe it helps that as a kid, Marcus never even liked boxing. He did it to please his dad, a college track star who almost went to the Olympics and dreamed of turning Marcus into the heavyweight champion of the world. "You're going to be my ticket out of the ghetto," he'd tell Marcus at 13.
马库斯之所以是个好老师，是因为他不是一个过度急切的父母。也许有帮助的是，马库斯小时候甚至不喜欢拳击。他是为了取悦他的父亲才这么做的，他的父亲是一位大学田径明星，差点进入奥运会，梦想着把马库斯培养成世界重量级冠军。“你将是我离开贫民窟的门票，”他曾在他13岁时对马库斯说。
Then after Marcus's mother died and his father got caught up in the wave of crack that hit the neighborhood in the mid-'80s. his father lost his job, the power got cut off, and Marcus still kept boxing, because the guys at the gym were the only ones who looked after him. They fed him, drove him to school, let him stay with them sometimes. As he told me in the car one day, it was the only part of his life with any promise.
后来在马库斯的母亲去世后，他的父亲陷入了80年代中期席卷该社区的毒品浪潮。父亲丢了工作，电被停了，马库斯却坚持练拳，因为健身房里的人是他身边唯一照看他的人。他们给他饭吃，送他上学，有时让他跟他们住在一起。正如他有一天在车里对我说的，那是他生活中唯一有希望的部分。
I was boxing and I never liked it. But I started making myself like it because I wanted some nice things. I wanted the nice life. I used to tell the guys at the car lot-- I was, like, ninth grade, 10th grade-- you know, what? When I win a gold medal, I'll make the Olympic team or turn pro, I'll be the champion of the world, I'm going to come and buy a car from you. And it was like, OK, all right young man, keep on, hang in there. You know, all right. [PHONE RINGS] Speak to me. I would like to have at least two big screens.
我在打拳，但我从来不喜欢它。但我开始强迫自己喜欢它，因为我想要一些美好的东西。我想要美好的生活。我过去常跟汽车场的人说——那时候我读九年级、十年级——你知道吗？当我赢了金牌，进入奥运队或转为职业选手，成为世界冠军时，我会回来买你们的车。他们就说，好，好，年轻人，坚持住。你知道，好的。[电话响]跟我说。我想至少有两个大屏幕。
Marcus is driving around doing errands for a party he's planning at the gym. He's invited around 70 people, friends and clients, to come watch the Oscar De La Hoya-Sugar Shane Mosley fight. The party's in a few days and Marcus is bringing in two huge televisions, catered soul food, and security to watch the door.
马库斯正开车四处奔波，为他在拳馆策划的一个派对办事。他邀请了大约70个人，朋友和客户，来看奥斯卡·德拉·霍亚和舒格·肖恩·莫斯利的比赛。派对几天后举行，马库斯正在租用两台巨大的电视、订购南方食物，并雇保安来看门。
Most of his clients are agents, producers, and writers for TV shows-- bigwigs, but behind- the-scenes bigwigs, no one whose name you'd know. Marcus needs more clients. He's had the gym for less than a year and the rent is high. The party is wiping him out, but he doesn't want to talk about that.
他的大多数客户是电视节目的代理人、制片人和编剧——大人物，但背后的幕后大人物，没有一个是你名字叫得出的人。马库斯需要更多客户。他开拳馆不到一年，房租很高。派对让他耗尽了钱财，但他不想谈论那个。
He gets back into the car after a quick stop at the bank.
从银行匆匆回来后，他又坐进车里。
I ain't happy. Well, I am happy, but I ain't. I ain't got no money. I'm broke. No, no. I got money, but--
我不快乐。嗯，我很快乐，但我又不是。我没钱。我破产了。不，不。我有钱，但——
I hate that. Is the party tapping you out?
我讨厌这样。派对让你掏空了吗？
No. I mean, I know I got money. I mean, I'm cool. What? I got money. I got an abundant amount of money. Oh, I got money flowing. Woo-hoo, boy. I got loot. I got millions, baby. For real.
没有。我的意思是，我知道我有钱。我的意思是，我很酷。什么？我有钱。我有大量的钱。噢，我钱多得流油。呜呼，伙计。我有钱。我有几百万，宝贝。真的。
Marcus's single-minded goal since he was little has been to be happy. A lot of people find happiness too abstract, or maybe too ambitious a goal to aim for. But to Marcus, it's very real. It's something he trains for, and plans for, and believes in. He has a commitment to being happy. When he's not enjoying something anymore, he just stops it-- stops doing it, stops thinking it, stops talking about it. It's hard work. It's daily work.
马库斯从小到大唯一的单一目标就是快乐。很多人觉得幸福太抽象，或者可能是一个太雄心勃勃的追求目标。但对马库斯来说，它是非常真实的。这是他训练、计划并相信的东西。他致力于让自己快乐。当他不再享受某件事时，他就会停止——停止做，停止想，停止谈论它。这很难。这是每天的工作。
Like in the car at the bank. He won't talk about not having money. He'll pretend he does have money. Like when I watch him get some bad news from a credit card company in the mail. He just stops himself in the middle of getting mad about it and says, "I'm hungry." Like when he started teaching boxing, he made a rule. No hitting in the face. Just because he always hated it. It hurt.
就像在银行的车里。他不会谈论没钱。他会假装自己有钱。就像我看着他在邮件里收到信用卡公司的坏消息。他会在生气到一半时停下来对自己说：“我饿了。”就像他开始教拳击时，他定了一条规矩。不许打脸。就因为他一直讨厌那样。太疼了。
So at his gym, you learn to punch hard, move your feet, and keep your stamina up. But no hitting in the face.
所以在他的拳馆，你学习重拳出击、移动脚步、保持体力。但不许打脸。
He still doesn't like boxing. But boxing is what he knows. He wants to use it to get to the point where he can stop boxing. What he really wants is to be an actor, a model, both of which he's done a little bit of. Whenever one of his clients brings a celebrity by the gym-- Puff Daddy, Mark Wahlberg, Ice Cube-- he can just feel it. He's getting closer.
他仍然不喜欢拳击。但拳击是他所知道的东西。他想利用它达到不再需要打拳的地步。他真正想做的是成为演员、模特，这两者他都做过一点。每当他的客户带名人来拳馆——吹牛老爹、马克·沃尔伯格、冰块酷——他都能感觉得到。他离目标更近了。
Can you believe somebody hitting this hard, he wrote Harriet the Spy . For children. And look at him. Rrrrr. Rrrrr. Harriet the Spy.
你能相信有人打拳打得这么好吗，他写了《哈丽特间谍》。给孩子看的。看看他。呼。呼。《哈丽特间谍》。
Marcus is in the ring with Doug Petrie, a television and screenplay writer. They're practicing a rapid-fire jab-hook-jab combination.
马库斯和电视及剧本作家道格·皮特里在拳台上。他们正在练习一套快速刺拳-勾拳-刺拳组合。
When Marcus first started getting more and more Hollywood people, like Doug, as clients, he found he was afraid to speak a lot of the time. He'd hear a voice in his head telling him--
当马库斯刚开始有越来越多好莱坞人士，比如道格这样的客户时，他发现自己经常害怕说话。他脑子里有个声音告诉他——
Man, just be quiet. Just shut up, don't say nothing. Just don't ask no questions. Or you are going to make yourself look bad, don't look like no fool.
伙计，安静点。闭嘴，别说话。别问问题。否则你会让自己看起来很糟糕，别像个傻瓜一样。
So he made a decision that he was just going to stop worrying all the time about looking bad in front of these rich, college-educated white people. It was miserable. He made a change.
所以他决定不再整天担心在这些富有、受过大学教育的白人面前看起来很糟糕。这太痛苦了。他做出了改变。
I used to listen to people all the time and say the words that they said. And use the words like they use them.
我过去总是听着别人，重复他们说的话。像他们一样使用词汇。
And he really does this. I heard him do it with me. We were in the middle of a long talk about the fears that learning to box can help overcome, and somehow the word conjuring came up.
而且他真的这么做了。我听到他对我这么做。我们当时正在进行一场关于学习拳击如何克服恐惧的长谈，不知怎么地“施法”这个词出来了。
We fear the unknown. And it's things that come to us, like in our mind, what we-- what word am I looking for? Not dream, but conjugate up, condur--
我们恐惧未知。那是来到我们头脑里的东西，什么——我在找什么词？不是梦，而是施展、施……
Conjuring up.
施法。
The fears that you conjure up.
你施加的恐惧。
Fears that you conjure up, but those--
你施加的恐惧，但那些——
He went back to the word four minutes later, making sure he'd got it.
四分钟后，他又回到这个词，确保他弄懂了。
Because he's going to conju-- con-- say that word again.
因为他要施……施……再说那个词。
Conjure.
施法。
Conjure. He's going to conjure up just different-- what if somebody jumped from out behind the alley and want to take my purse. All those things are conjured up in your mind.
施法。他要施加各种不同的东西——如果有人从巷子后面跳出来想抢我的包怎么办。所有这些东西都是在你脑子里施加出来的。
15 minutes later, he used it again, when he was talking about his own fear, his fear of speaking. And this time when he said it, he looked at me and laughed, because he knew he was doing it.
15分钟后，当他谈到自己的恐惧，对说话的恐惧时，他又用了一次。这一次他说的时候，他看着我笑了，因为他知道自己在这么做。
I'm listening to people talk all the time. They're doing deals on the phone and these business people. And I'm going, I want to be able to, you know, conjure up words and sound smart.
我一直听着别人说话。他们在电话里谈生意，那些商务人士。我在想，我想能，你知道，施加词汇，听起来聪明。
Los Angeles, like every other big city in America, is segregated between black and white. But it's more complete here. The dividing line is the 10 freeway. North of it is West Hollywood, Beverly Hills, Hollywood. South of it, where Marcus grew up, is Inglewood, South Central, Watts. The separation is so complete that if you live north of the 10 it's possible to go for a week without laying eyes on a single black person.
洛杉矶，像美国每一个大城市一样，在黑人和白人之间被隔离。但在这一带更彻底。分界线是10号高速公路。北边是西好莱坞、比佛利山庄、好莱坞。南边，马库斯长大的地方，是英格尔伍德、中南部、沃茨。隔离是如此彻底，以至于如果你住在10号公路以北，可能一个星期都见不到一个黑人。
Only a certain kind of person ever makes the jump from one side of the 10 to the other. And one of the things that makes Marcus capable of it is that it's not a chore for him to find out about new things. He's curious about them. He enjoys it. In high school, when he spent a year at a mostly white school, he started getting into heavy metal, Quiet Riot. Now he eats an organic salad for lunch every day, the kind of food he'd never even heard of growing up.
只有特定类型的人才会从10号公路的一边跳到另一边。马库斯之所以能做到这一点，原因之一是他发现新事物对他来说不是苦差事。他对它们感到好奇。他很享受。在高中时，当他在一所大部分是白人的学校待了一年时，他开始迷上重金属摇滚，如“Quiet Riot”。现在他每天午餐吃有机沙拉，这是他长大时从未听说过的食物。
The party is in two days. Marcus is sprucing up. He's already had a manicure and now he's at his sister Michelle's cosmetology class to get his hair rebraided. Michelle is going to show the class how to braid by doing Marcus's hair.
派对两天后举行。马库斯正在装扮自己。他已经做过美甲，现在在姐姐米歇尔的美容班让他重新编辫子。米歇尔要向全班展示如何通过做马库斯的头发来编辫子。
He walks through the room introducing himself to everyone, a process that involves a blend of charm, attentiveness and self-effacement so potent that the room feels giddy by the end of it. It's not just because he's 6'1", high cheekbones, model good looks, huge smile. His charm doesn't only work with women. I've seen him work it over the phone with strangers, with someone he cut off in his car. He's interested in people. He asks where they're from, where they live. He notices things about them.
他走进房间，向每个人介绍自己，这个过程融合了魅力、专注和谦逊，以至于到最后整个房间都感到头晕目眩。这不仅仅是因为他身高6英尺1英寸，高颧骨，模特般的帅气容貌，灿烂的笑容。他的魅力不仅对女性有效。我见过他在电话里对陌生人，对他车里插队的人使用。他关心人。他问他们来自哪里，住哪里。他注意到了关于他们的细节。
While his head is under a faucet a friend of Michelle's is standing next to him, holding the shampoo.
当他的头在水龙头下时，米歇尔的一个朋友站在他旁边，拿着洗发水。
How old is your child?
你的孩子多大了？
Two. You said, how old is my child? Two.
两岁。你问，我的孩子多大了？两岁。
Two. Boy?
两岁。男孩？
Girl.
女孩。
He said, how old is your child? I was trying to figure out how he knew I had a child too.
他说，你的孩子多大了？我当时在想他是怎么知道我也有孩子的。
Maybe it was just a lucky guess. I ask Marcus about it later, how he'd known she had a child. And he couldn't tell me. He didn't know how he knew. He just had a feeling.
也许这只是一个幸运的猜测。后来我问马库斯这件事，他是怎么知道她有孩子的。他无法告诉我。他不知道自己怎么知道的。他只是有一种预感。
I'm going to have the VIP seat. A VIP going to be able to sit in the ring and watch the fight.
我会有一个VIP席位。VIP将能够坐在拳台上观看比赛。
Nice.
不错。
It's the afternoon of the party and Marcus is all energy. He's arranging chairs, checking the angle of the two big TVs, one of which is blaring the movie About Last Night.
这是派对当天的下午，马库斯充满了精力。他正在安排椅子，检查两台大电视的角度，其中一台正大声播放电影《昨夜》。
The pre-fights don't start for another two hours. The main event is in five hours. The caterers are setting up tables for the food.
垫场赛两个小时后开始。主赛在五个小时后。餐饮服务商正在为食物摆放桌子。
They can adjust them. They can move them closer if they want to. You know, this ain't no [UNINTELLIGIBLE], they better fix them chairs where they can see. It's like a backyard barbecue. I know we here in Hollywood, and Hollywood is going to be in here, but we doing it the old-fashioned way. You better get your plate on, your paper plate, and get your plastic fork and spoon and your water. It's all good.
他们可以调整它们。他们如果想的话可以把它们移近。你知道，这不是什么[模糊]，他们最好把椅子固定好，这样他们能看到。这就像后院烧烤。我知道我们在好莱坞，好莱坞的人会来这里，但我们要用老派的方式做。你最好拿好你的盘子，你的纸盘子，拿好你的塑料叉子和勺子还有水。一切都很好。
In 45 minutes the food is set up. It smells great, and there's a ton of it, enough for 100 people-- cornbread, macaroni and cheese, fried chicken. Everything's all set. The TVs are on the right channel. The doors are open.
45分钟后，食物准备好了。闻起来很棒，而且量很大，足够100人享用——玉米面包、通心粉奶酪、炸鸡。一切都准备就绪。电视调到了正确的频道。门开了。
Over the next several hours, people trickle in. Some family, some friends from Inglewood and South Central, Marcus's pastor, people he knew from boxing. But Hollywood never shows up. Clients he's had for three years, people whose Passover Seders he's attended. Only two of Marcus's clients come by, and one of them is the kid, Josh.
接下来的几个小时里，人们零星进场。一些家人，一些来自英格尔伍德和中南部的老朋友，马库斯的牧师，他在拳击中认识的人。但好莱坞的人从没出现过。他认识三年的客户，他参加过他们逾越节家宴的人。只有两个马库斯的客户路过，其中一个是那个孩子，乔希。
I'm one of about half a dozen white people. Marcus's frenzied party energy dissipates slowly over the hours. But he stays charming with everyone he talks to, seems genuinely happy to see the people who do come. His poise is painful to watch.
我是大约半打白人中的一个。马库斯的疯狂派对能量在几个小时里慢慢消散。但他对和他交谈的每一个人都保持魅力，看起来真的很高兴看到那些到来的人。他的镇定让人看了心疼。
During the five hours of the party, and in the days afterward, I never hear him suggest that anything that night is a disappointment. If he ever thinks such a thought, I'm sure he stops himself.
在派对的五个小时里，以及之后的日子里，我从未听到他暗示当晚有什么令人失望的事情。如果他曾经有这样的想法，我相信他阻止了自己。
There's something I haven't told you about Marcus. Two weeks before I started interviewing him for this story, he found God. As Marcus puts it, he gave his life to Christ. The whole time I was interviewing him, all I wanted to talk about was what he did to get where he is, and all he wanted to talk about was how God was the real force behind every good thing in his life. It frustrated me. Marcus's faith kept intruding on the story I wanted to get.
关于马库斯，有件事我还没告诉你。在我开始采访他写这个故事的两周前，他找到了上帝。正如马库斯所说，他把生命交给了基督。我采访他的整个过程中，我想谈论的都是他如何达到现在的地位，而他想谈论的都是上帝如何是他生命中每一件好事背后的真正力量。这让我很沮丧。马库斯的信仰一直干扰着我想写的故事。
I wanted to know about Marcus's life, his experiences, his choices, the hard work of creating a happy life. That was going to be my whole point in this story, that we pretend happiness is some natural state we would just fall into if we stopped running around being so ambitious and greedy and self-obsessed. When, in fact, it takes tremendous effort to be happy.
我想知道马库斯的生活、他的经历、他的选择、创造幸福生活的艰苦努力。那将是我这个故事的全部要点，我们假装幸福是一种自然状态，如果我们停止四处奔波、变得如此野心勃勃、贪婪和自我沉迷，我们就会自然而然地陷入其中。而事实上，要快乐需要巨大的努力。
But if I'm looking at Marcus as a study in how to be happy, then there's something besides hard work that you need to be happy. You need faith. Not necessarily religious faith, although in Marcus's case it is. But you do need to believe that happiness is possible. You need to accept that. That's what God gave Marcus.
但如果我把马库斯作为如何快乐的研究对象，那么除了努力工作之外，还需要一些东西才能快乐。你需要信仰。不一定是宗教信仰，尽管在马库斯的情况下是。但你确实需要相信幸福是可能的。你需要接受这一点。那就是上帝给马库斯的东西。
My motto is "Feed the faith and starve the doubt." Now I just have faith. I just got faith. I'm out here on faith. I did everything on faith.
我的座右铭是“喂养信仰，饿死怀疑”。现在我只有信仰。我只是有了信仰。我依靠信仰在外打拼。我所做的一切都是依靠信仰。
What did you go on, how did you keep going before you started believing in God again?
你在开始重新相信上帝之前依靠什么？你怎么坚持下去的？
This is what I'm telling you. I was just going without the belief of God. I just was going on just my strength, courage and faith. And I wasn't going to quit. I was going to find out. I wanted the life that I wanted. And I wanted a life of peace and happiness. I wanted heaven on earth, that's what I wanted. I lived on this street here. When I started boxing, I started boxing on this block right here.
这就是我要告诉你的。我过去只是在没有上帝信仰的情况下前行。我只是凭借我的力量、勇气和信仰前行。我不会放弃。我会找出来的。我想要我想要的生活。我想要一种和平与幸福的生活。我想要人间天堂，那就是我想要的。我住在这条街上。我开始练拳时，就是在这条街上开始练拳的。
We're driving down the street Marcus lived on when he was 13, Manhattan Place. His godmother still lives on the block.
我们开车经过马库斯13岁时住的那条街，曼哈顿坊。他的教母仍然住在那个街区。
Hi, Ms. Culvert.
嗨，卡尔弗特女士。
Heya.
嘿呀。
Hi, ma.
嗨，妈。
How you doing, son?
你好吗，儿子？
Fine.
很好。
We only stay for a few minutes, just long enough for him to tell her the big news.
我们只待了几分钟，足够他告诉她那个重大消息了。
Guess what?
你猜怎么着？
What?
什么？
I gave my life to Christ, who saved me.
我把生命交给了基督，他拯救了我。
Praise the Lord.
赞美主。
He saved me. Mother's Day.
他拯救了我。母亲节。
That's the greatest that you ever could have done in life.
那是你一生中能做的最伟大的事。
He saved me Mother's Day.
他拯救了我，母亲节。
That's the greatest thing you could have ever done in life.
那是你一生中能做的最伟大的事。
I said to myself, what have I been doing this whole time?
我对自已说，我这一整段时间都在干什么？
OK. Nothing like being in the hands of the Lord, is there? Nothing.
好的。没有什么比在主的掌握之中更好的了，不是吗？什么都没有。
Nothing.
没有。
See why I stay with it?
你看我为什么坚持下去？
At this point, she abruptly turns to me while Marcus is still talking and asks, "Do you know God?" I shake my head, and she gives me a look so startling, a combination of bewilderment, pity and disgust. And then she turns away.
就在这时，当马库斯还在说话时，她突然转向我问道：“你认识上帝吗？”我摇了摇头，她给了我一个令人吃惊的眼神，混合了困惑、怜悯和厌恶。然后她转过身去。
We can't stay long. I've got to get ready to go. I just stopped by to just say hi.
我们不能待太久。我得准备走了。我只是顺便过来打个招呼。
OK. All right, good to see you.
好的。好的，很高兴见到你。
And give you a hug and say, God bless you.
给你一个拥抱，说声上帝保佑你。
We get in the car and drive back across the 10.
我们上车开车穿回10号公路。
I love you.
我爱你。
Love you too, baby. You know we do. Hurry back, now.
也爱你，宝贝。你知道我们爱你。快回来。
All right.
好的。
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普代克。
Our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself with Alex Blumberg and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike and consiglierie Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Hillary Frank.
今天的节目由布鲁·切维尼和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格和朱莉·斯奈德共同参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责维护我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和希拉里·弗兰克提供制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org.
要购买本期或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ办公室。电话：312-832-3380。或者您可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who begins every staff meeting with his weird diatribes about fictional child detectives.
WBEZ的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚，他每次员工会议都以他对虚构儿童侦探的怪异长篇大论开头。
Rrrrr. Rrrrr. Harriet the Spy.
呼。呼。《哈丽特间谍》。
Harriet the Spy , indeed. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
确实是《哈丽特间谍》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。